hi I'm mano marks developer advocate on
the Google Maps API team this is the
third video in a series of four designed
to show you how to get started with the
Google Maps JavaScript API in the last
video I covered getting an API key for
the Google Maps JavaScript API in this
the video will cover using the key when
loading the JavaScript API and the
basics of using the Google Maps loader
the Google Maps JavaScript API is loaded
using a script tag the basic format
looks like this you can see that there
are two parameters both required if
you're going to use an API key common
mistake people make is to copy and paste
this text without changing the
parameters the Maps API will not load in
this case first replace API key with
your API key and then set the sensor to
either true or false in most cases it
will probably be false for example look
at this this will pass both the key and
tell Google whether you are creating a
map that uses a sensor to detect the
location of the user and then on the
sensor parameter you must set this to
true or false but it doesn't change the
capabilities of the Maps API if you are
using a sensor there's no additional
data that you get there's no cost
associated with it and likewise if
you're not we must collect this
information to provide back to our data
providers that's the only reason we
collect it there are a few optional
parameters though that you should be
aware of the first is a language
parameter it by specifying the language
parameter you are changing the default
language of the map both the map tiles
and the controls in this example by
using J a would change the map to
Japanese we support both left to right
and right to left languages for instance
if you chose a R for Arabic you will see
right-to-left
when you do this however you should
specify dir equals RT ion the div
containing any R RTL text
lastly we
include a library's perimeter this is to
load in the Google Maps API libraries
that provide additional functionality of
the API but should only be loaded if
they are required for more information
see the library's documentation at this
URL that's all for this episode in the
next episode we'll cover the basic Maps
options used to create your first map